Here is a visualization of the agent
based simulation of the Center for
Health Discovery and Well-being.
A special clinic established
to explore the potential for
preventing the development
of chronic disease.
Here you can see physical areas,
such as the education room Where
trained coaches interact with patients.
When the simulation is actually run, all
the clinic personnel and the patients
being served move along these pathways
governed by the time it takes to
do each element of the clinics work, the
available resources and other factors.
The simulation was constructed to help
the clinic identify a set of processes
and a revenue model that would
make it both self-sustaining and
of value to its parent organization.